- Well, I heard that you
were attacked by a bear once-
- [Neve] Yes, ya.
- Which I find fascinating.
(person laughing)
So you're a survivor.
Um, so what was that like,
was it in Canada?
- It was in Canada,
but it's not like I was,
it was not when we were
camping or anything,
it was actually on a movie, I was-
- [Kelly] What?
- Yeah, I was 17 years old,
and I was, yeah, playing
this role where she's,
one with the animals, and-
(people laughing)
- [Kelly] That's ironic.
- Yes.
And there was, there was
a scene where I'm supposed
to be getting chased by a bear.
The only animal I'm not
one within the movie.
And they just, they
brought this bear on set
and they said, you know,
dip your hand in hot,
no, they first gave me a big
bottle of Coke to feed it.
And I thought-
- Coca-Cola.
- Yeah. Coca-Cola.
So now this is like a
bear on a sugar rush.
And then they said, and I'm 17,
so I'm really dumb.
And they give me, they say,
dip your hand in honey and just run.
And when you get to the tree over there,
turn around and stick your
hand out and feed the bear.
And I, of course wanting to
please everyone was like, okay.
- And you're thinking obviously
I'm in a safe environment.
Someone has done this before me.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I dip my hand in honey
and I run to this rock
or this tree they told me to go to
and I turn around and I put my hand out
and the bear's not slowing down
and he is not coming from my hand.
And he grabs me by the leg
and he pulls me through
the forest and my mother
happens to be visiting set.
So she's screaming, the
whole crew's frozen,
because no one can
believe what's happening.
And it's, and all I could do,
all I could think to
say was he's biting me.
Like it wasn't obvious.
(people laughing)
- Just if it's not clear.
- Just in case nobody
knows, he's biting me.
- Oh my God.
- Pulled me through the
forest and then finally the,
the bear wrangler starts
just throwing rocks
at the bear to get it off me,
and it finally gets pissed off
and turns around and goes after him.
And I run a, I go up a rock, um, yeah-
- Please tell me right after that,
they were like, okay, well, okay,
the next take, we wanted,
no I'm just kidding-
- No, they did, no, they did, they say.
They were like, we're not doing it again.
And I was like, again,
this people pleaser.
I was like, no, that was rehearsal.
We didn't get it on camera.
Let's do it.
- Oh my God, actors are so
different from musicians.
(person laughing)
I'm like, I can't express this enough.
I, I like literally,
if I was in a music video
and some like that went down,
I couldn't say that word on daytime.
I would be like, bye.
- So would I, now.
- CGI, get my stunt double in.
I'm like what.
Actors, I always find funny.
You all, these insane
things happen to you all.
- So silly.
But we get asked to do
really silly things as well.
I'm old, I'm older now.
I'm like, I'm old now actually.
- Yeah I know, no, I'm
old too, and I'm like,
I learned that word "no" real well.
(people laughing)
- Oh, for sure.
- Yeah.
- For sure. Like, no, absolutely not.
- Oh, that's crazy.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And your mom that nightmare from hell.
- Oh yeah it was bad.